honestly Bobby be real with yourself dig
deep I want you to look me in the eyes
like
are you like bi
[Music]
wow that's how I needed am I bi no at
all like you've never wanted like well I
mean I know my I know that what I
masturbate to
is you know what I mean it's like um
only one time in my life there's one
video on PornHub that has one video with
a man who's has a a woman that has a
penis it's the only time I've ever kind
of stroked my penis to something it's
hot though honestly like and she's
beautiful they're all hot yeah yeah
they're so hot to me but I have like
male friends who like love trans girls
and like I get it like I find them
attractive yeah
there's nothing wrong if if if
Andrea said I've divorced my wife right
and said you know I mean I'm dating you
know trans I wouldn't do anything no
there would be no judgment yeah I mean I
mean good for you bro you know what I
mean yeah Grays as a woman right oh man
but I don't think I
you know
I think I know my Character defects and
I know
because I think about myself all the
time
that's gonna get clipped out
no not in terms of like you know how
great I am I think about myself in terms
of I know this sounded weird I think
about myself in terms of like what I
have and haven't done and my behaviors
and you know and going why do I do this
there's something you know I mean even
like even showing you that photo of
being
looking at things about you know my
behaviors that seem to be either
um
not healthy and not and trying to fix
things so I'm always and and that thing
I've in terms of sexuality
um
do I have a problem kissing a man on the
lips no
would I tongue a guy on the stage to get
a laugh 100 would I would I dock my
penis into another man's penis 100 100
yeah but only for entertainment purposes
what if it's not comedy no
I will not what's the point
well I I would do it okay you're right
all right I'll break it down break it
down I would do it to see if it worked
the docking yeah I knew because you're
very curious I'm very curious that's why
you know I'm science minded in many ways
I have a question about docking do you
need to have foreskin or just one person
with foreskin uh I would think that you
if you and I could you have foreskin
right yeah I can almost dock with I'm a
universal USB I conduct you're like a
type O blood basically typo you're a
universal donor exactly but there are
guys I'm sure you've met guys and that
have like regular or not mine's regular
but uh they are it's irregular no that's
not true I thought about this I thought
about this and I don't think that I
would circumcise my sons
okay
thank you Zone
if you think about it I'll cut it if
they don't do it it's like kind of like
this weird like I grew up in a country
where it's like this legit mutilation
they have kids line up when they're
seven years old and they just get
kamungai and then it's like this plant
like herbal thing and then they chop
these [__] pores but if you don't
chop it how korean's gonna make the skin
cream
Alessandra Bullock yeah look as young as
she does you know okay we have the job
we have to Chopper yeah for Sandra yeah
but um but like no normal there's other
penises that have skin like you guys can
okay am I crazy here can you put your
skin over your penis tip yes oh yeah
yeah everyone can die I have saggy skin
though you don't
no it's sagging
I think what I think honestly my sister
I look so concerned yeah I think I did
it to myself because I jerk off so much
because I think I just the the the stick
the stem is loose
no no regular okay thank you that's all
I wanted to hear yeah go ahead no no I
have technical information that probably
you won't be happy with uh I think
no I think uh when um
I've never heard anyone sound so white
than that nickel
off a penis conversation yeah it's
really white uh and and you got it you
gotta you gotta hold back a little bit
because it's you're freaking me out
right now dude so just start over with
the technical line go ahead okay I have
a son and uh he has a baby so he's very
excited that's so racist what is
happening just go back to technical go
back to technical because whatever
you're doing now is even worse uh uh
he's fat so it's kind of like yeah
babies have a fupa so it like pushes
their Force get their skin over so even
if they're circumcised it seems like
they have a foreskin yeah so I think
it's uh just because you got a little
bit uh anyway if it pushes your yeah
anyways you have a baby penis I think
that he's saying you have a baby penis
because your food
that's insane okay I get it dimensional
but like not Dimensions
basically he's like you have a fupa and
that's the reason why it creates a
foreskin even though you have a baby
penis is what he's saying can you can
you believe he just said that okay I
can't believe you just said that and I
have that's what's technical he finds
out hey technically you're fat so you
have horses this is a medical opinion
and this is a true thing I'm going to
say on the bus when me and Andrew on
tour
it was three in the morning and I got
erect okay just by being there hanging
with him just be with Andrew no just
sometimes it just gets my penis will
just go we're up yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah morning but it was like three in
the morning wood okay I'm trying to help
you out okay thank you so and I just
pulled it out I showed Andrew and he
went he I gasped
it doesn't look that it's like a very
regular penis thank you so much anyway
let's go back to docking yeah
um because I'm not I am circumcised and
you're not I think it'd be easier for I
think one needs to be certain so you
could have the skin that'll wrap the
other penis right yeah but if both
there's two wraps right I don't know how
that works that would be fun yeah yeah
fun no that'd be difficult difficult
yeah yeah maybe get it a little sweaty
so it really sticks let's go back to
being bi yeah yeah can we go back there
being by let's do that yeah um but no I
don't think I am
I learned this thing
rehab like any serial killers
that so hard to believe it is hard I
mean there's obviously like very like
[__] up